you have no idea do you what did you
choose not to know your husband stole
two million dollars for me this is about
my life
[Music]
this is above my life
because it's about my life and that
becomes about yours
so that happen today something better
mr. Malla can your family's been
involved in Harry's life for many years
I need help I don't see what I can do
our husbands aren't coming back
Ron oh my husband left me the plans for
his next job
all honey it is a cool to pull it off
why should we trust you anyway
because I'm the only one standing
between you and a bullet in your head
that's what I've learned from men like
your late husband and my father that you
reap what you sow let's hope so
[Applause]
[Music]
this is for guns guns from where figure
it out
if this whole thing goes wrong I want my
kids to know that I didn't just sit
there and take it
I did something
[Music]
now the best thing we have going for is
is being who we are why because no one
thinks we have the balls to pull this
off
[Music]
you